how did miles teller get his facial
scars and what impact did the accident
that caused them have on his acting
career keep watching to find out
miles teller just has one of those faces
the actor has built an impressive resume
over the course of the past decade
starring in both blockbuster action
movies and character-driven independent
films in equal measure and while some
audiences might not have previously
recognized teller the long-awaited
sequel to 1986's top gun top gun
maverick has likely changed that teller
plays bradley rooster bradshaw the son
of pete maverick mitchells former radio
intercept officer best friend and
partner in crime nick goose bradshaw
played by anthony edwards in the
original film the resemblance between
these two unrelated actors is downright
eerie making tellers casting a fitting
choice teller made his feature film
debut in 2010's rabbit hole in which he
starred opposite nicole kidman in the
2011 remake of footloose he took on the
role of willard a good natured guy with
two left feet teller's breakout
performance was in the 2013 coming of
age drama the spectacular now which won
the special jury prize at the sundance
film festival and proved that teller
could hold his own as a leading man for
the first time some of his other film
credits include the oscar-nominated
whiplash the fantastic four and the
divergent trilogy given his wide-ranging
success as a performer it's hard to
believe there was once a time when
teller was turned away after auditions
because of his facial scars during an
interview with the abc news's popcorn
with peter travers teller revealed that
his face was wounded and subsequently
scarred during his young adulthood which
then affected his burgeoning acting
career when he was 20 years old and
attending college teller was injured in
a serious car accident after his friend
lost control of a vehicle while driving
at 80 miles per hour the car rolled
eight times in total and ejected teller
50 feet away we flipped like eight times
going 80 miles per hour and i actually
flew out my window after being thrown
from the vehicle the actor ended up in
such bad shape that his friend thought
he might be dead fortunately teller
survived the incident after sustaining
some significant injuries to his face
following the accident teller underwent
multiple painful surgeries to remove the
scar tissue resulting from his wounds
over the course of roughly four years as
it turns out he still has some pieces of
gravel embedded in his face which his
doctors said would cause even more
damage if removed rather than if left
alone for a while teller's appearance
after the car accident stood in the way
of his acting ambitions as he told abc
news when i first started auditioning
people were straight up just like yeah
miles is a good actor but it doesn't
make sense for this character to have
scars the scars used to be really bad
but i was very surprised about how
comfortable people felt just being like
man what happened to your face soon
however one director took a chance on
teller when others would not putting him
on the career trajectory he maintains
today as teller revealed in his
interview with peter travers rabbit hole
director john cameron mitchell didn't
just cast him in his debut feature in
spite of his facial scars instead the
director saw the scars as a strength
teller recounts mitchell characterizing
his scars as adding a new dimension to
his character in the film beyond the
mystique with which they imbue teller's
character in rabbit hole he portrays the
driver of a car that killed a young boy
in a happenstance accident so the
real-life source of his scars parallel
this fictional incident teller would
then go on to appear in the spectacular
now and whiplash both of which include
pivotal scenes in which teller's
character is involved in car accidents
so in the end rather than his facial
scars hindering him they seemingly
became part of his identity as an actor
as it turned out teller's scars helped
to shape him and led him to roles for
which this aspect of his appearance
became a unique strength of course
tyler's filmography isn't limited to
just films featuring car accidents as
evidenced by his marquee role in top gun
maverick when teller's casting was
announced back in 2018 he beat out both
nicholas holt and glenn powell alongside
whom he tested for the role it's safe to
say that at this stage teller is
unencumbered by his injuries and the
hardships it caused early on in his
career
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]